No sé, Adri, Álex, Nao, si estáis preparados para el último Q&A de esta Liga 2024-2025.
¿El último ya?
El último.
The last, the dance.
Nunca es el último.
En este caso sí, no de la temporada, pero sí de la Liga y como siempre,
en honor a lo que ha sido esta Liga 2024-2025, viene variadito y picadito.
¿Qué pasa, pizarritas?
Ya estamos aquí con un nuevo Q&A de la Liga, el último, en el que vamos a hablar un poquito
de lo que hay en juego, evidentemente este próximo fin de semana, cuestiones de mercado,
balance, nos vamos a preguntar por el mejor momento de la Liga, la mejor actuación,
fichajes decepcionantes que pueden mejorar la próxima temporada.
Hoy, chicos, tenemos plancha, que se suele decir.
Hoy, por ser el último, propongo un jueguito, facilito, rapidito.
Ya empezamos.
Papel y boli.
Apuntad cuánto creéis que va a durar el Q&A y a ver quién se acerca más al final del vídeo.
Pero no vale luego hacer trampas, no vale que Álex de Llano apunte 2 horas y 27 y empieza
a dar datos como un puto loco.
Que no tengo cerca el papel y boli.
Yo me lo he apuntado aquí en el blog de notas.
En el blog de notas voy a poner aquí el tal.
Yo me lo he puesto ya.
Va.
Venga.
Vale.
Este es un juego al que los pizarritas no pueden jugar, claro, pero bueno.
Claro.
Oye.
Hombre, sería trampa, ¿no?
Podrías entrar al vídeo sin ver la duración, poner la pantalla completa, ¿no?
Y la gente flipando.
Y dejándose llevar.
La duración de los Q&A parece los de una vuelta de clasificación en Mónaco ya.
Pero no de Aston Martin.
De momento.
Bueno.
Bueno, cuidado.
Vamos.
Hay Mónaco, ¿no?
Hay gran premio de Mónaco este fin de semana.
Bueno, chicos, vamos con la primera cuestión.
Vamos a empezar por las dos cuestiones más relevantes de este fin de semana.
Permanencia y Europa.
Pregunta Adrián.
¿Español o leganés?
¿Quién baja?
¿Quién desciende?
¿Quién se salva?
¿Cómo lo veis, chicos?
Creo que leganés.
Creo que leganés es el que acaba perdiendo la categoría.
Creo que ha ido muy justito durante toda la temporada.
Creo que van a ganar los dos y que finalmente descenderá el leganés.
Creo que los dos sacan el partido delante.
¿Cómodo?
Creo que va a...
Mira, creo que va a adelantarse primero el leganés.
Creo que va a marcar pronto el leganés.
Eso va a meterle un poco el miedo en el cuerpo al español.
Pero creo que van a ganar los dos sus partidos.
A ver.
Yo creo que al final el que depende de sí mismo es el español.
Juega contra un equipo que ya lo vimos el otro día frente al leganés.
Está un poco out.
Es verdad que no es el último partido de la Unión Deportiva de las Palmas.
Tiene un partido en San Antonio, en Estados Unidos,
por el hermanamiento de las dos ciudades.
No, no.
Pero quiero decir que esto todavía para el jugador...
Sí.
Estoy seguro que están celebrando el hermanamiento con San Antonio.
Claro, claro.
Seguro que están súper felices de tener que estar una semana más
teniendo que formar parte de la disciplina y no poder irse de vacaciones.
Así que, bueno, yo me imagino que va a ser un partido
que si el español es capaz de competir fuerte los 10, 15 primeros minutos,
para mí a partir de ahí,
yo creo que los jugadores de la Unión Deportiva de las Palmas,
no creo que haya jugadores que...
Moleiro es de la casa, etcétera,
pero no creo que se vaya a fastidiar un contrato a próximas temporadas
por meter más la pierna de lo debido en un partido
en el que no se juega nada ni él ni su equipo.
Pero fíjate, Alex, que yo aquí, más que mirar a las Palmas ya vaya Olis,
que yo preferiría enfrentarme a las Palmas...
Es mirarse a los dos equipos.
Es mirarse a uno mismo, claro.
Imagínate, 10, 15, 20 primeros minutos del español.
Tiene ocasiones, no transforma.
Escuchas el gol del Leganes.
Ya es jugar con tus propios fantasmas.
Yo creo que aquí el punto positivo del español,
que lo comentábamos el otro día,
es que tiene el precedente contra el Oviedo,
que tiene esa forma de gestionar y asimilar la presión
aunque haya cambios en la plantilla.
Eso es un precedente positivo,
pero para mí el rival, como quien dice, entre comillas,
en este caso es lo de menos.
A ver, lo del precedente está bien,
pero yo sobre todo apelo el discurso de normalidad
que le da, Manuel, que da sensación de saber gestionar
ese tipo de circunstancias,
y yo por ahí me fío, pero...
A ver, creo que todo lo que no sea pronosticar dos victorias
es raro ya no solo porque los dos son los que se juegan algo
y el rival no se juega nada, sino por el rival que hay enfrente,
por el tema de jugar en casa.
Sería lo más lógico.
Todo lo que no sea eso va a ser sorprendente, así que lo...
Vamos, ya sabéis que a mí me gusta llevar la contraria,
pero veo poco probable la permanencia del Leganes.
Hombre, sobre todo porque todos tenemos la impresión
de que en los cinco partidos que hay cosas en juego
alguno la puede liar, pero es que es muy difícil saber quién.
Porque, por ejemplo, en estos dos, es que son casos análogos,
Leganes y español, ante los otros dos descendidos y en casa,
como dice Nahuel, ni siquiera es el factor visitante en este caso.
Sí que hay más variedad en la pelea por Europa,
más allá de que creo que los cuatro...
No, pensamos que van a entrar Rayo y Celta,
que son los que tienen...
Bueno, los que dependen de sí mismo, ¿verdad, chicos?
Mm-hmm.
Vale.
Pregunta un aficionado de Osasuna, Kao Supporter,
si es mejor ir a Europa League que a la Conference
para conjuntos como Osasuna, Rayo o Celta.
Y aquí yo tengo que decir que me parece una pregunta lógica e ilegítima,
porque es verdad que la Europa League da más dinero que la Conference,
pero, pero, son dos partidos más,
probablemente de hecho cuatro, por el tema de la repesca,
es más fácil acceder directo en Conference que en Europa League.
El nivel de los rivales es muy diferente,
tú la Conference la puedes gestionar con una plantilla de Europa League,
si quieres meterte en repesca o en octavos,
me parece muy complicado gestionarlo de esa manera.
Y tres, es que como quien dice,
igual tienes que eliminar a dos rivales de tu nivel o superior
para ganar un título europeo.
Entonces, sé que igual queda un poquito luz en mi planteamiento,
pero yo me quedo con la Conference.
Yo no.
La Conference tiene fase previa y la Europa League no.
Ah, eso es verdad.
La fase previa destroza el de planificación.
Eso es verdad.
Que se lo digan a Osasuna.
Y que luego, que se le da la misma categoría,
ganar la Europa League, ganar la Conference,
si no la tiene.
No, pero, Nao, por eso pregunta para Osasuna, Rayo o Celta.
Quiero decir, si esto fuese Athletic Club,
fíjate, el Betis, que está jugando final de Conference,
pues bueno, te podría decir lo otro,
pero para Rayo, Celta o Osasuna,
que vamos a ver qué verano tienen, qué plantilla se les queda,
cómo pueden gestionar el compaginarlo con Liga,
yo me quedaría con Conference, pero es verdad lo que dice Ale,
es que el tema de la previa te condiciona la planificación,
te condiciona la pretemporada y encima te puedes ir a la calle.
Pero tú debes aspirar a jugar la mejor competición posible.
O sea, me parece una discusión de equipo pequeño dar por hecho,
que oye, que en Europa League no la vamos a ganar
y a ver si podemos ganar la Conference.
No, fíjate.
Pero fíjate, Nao, que no es tanto de equipo pequeño,
sino de aficionado consecuente con el verano que puedan hacer sus clubes.
Con las posibilidades.
Bueno, pero es que la exigencia en nivel de campeón
va a ser muy parecida y en Europa League te pagan el doble de dinero.
Yo creo que a nivel de dificultad la exigencia es muy diferente, o sea…
Esto es lo que decían en Mallorca,
que había rumro de si el equipo entraba en Europa o no,
porque igual el proyecto luego no estaba a la altura.
Luego le exigimos a los equipos españoles que se metan en Europa
que apuesten por Europa, oye.
Sí, pero…
Es consecuente con eso.
Pero estamos hablando de…
El Rayo se ha metido una vez en Europa,
y además fue por el tema del fair play.
O sea, es una…
Es verdad que se metió hace poquito en Conference,
cayó en la ronda previa precisamente como apuntaba Alex.
Hay que retocer bastante para encontrar aquellas…
Fueron semifinales de Copa de la UEFA.
Pero mira, sin salir de estos equipos…
Y Celta.
¿Cuánto llevaba el Celta sin meterse en Europa
cuando llega a las semifinales con el Manchester United?
Es que… Quiero decir, la competieron a mil maravillas.
Estuvo a punto de meterse en la final.
Pero ¿crees que es la…
Tenemos un caso de Granada también,
que nunca se había metido en Europa y compite muy bien.
¿Pero crees que es la misma plantilla, Nao, por ejemplo, de Celta?
Bueno, ya veremos. Ya veremos.
O sea, pero quiero decir, de partida,
de partida tú tienes que aspirar a meterte en Europa, Liz.
El debate de, oye, a ver si caigo en la Conference,
y con un poquito de suerte, en octavos no me toca ningún coco,
si me planto en semis,
que ya me encontraré con alguno de la Serie A o de la Premier.
No, no.
Vea por la Europa League y si te eliminas en la Europa League,
pues depende de quién te elimine, que se te elimina Rangers,
no va a ser lo mismo que te elimine el Tottenham.
Bueno, ya veremos.
Yo creo que hay aquí una situación muy clara,
que yo creo que el aficionado que viaja…
Creo que, por un lado, prefiere Conference
porque entiende que el viaje es más…
Se haga descubrir más.
O sea, que va a ir a un sitio que probablemente,
si no es por el fútbol, no iría.
Como el caso del Betis, el partido que jugó…
Me parece que era contra un rival de República Checa
que ahora mismo no me acuerdo del nombre,
pero creo que…
El Mlávole Slav creo que es el de…
Eso es.
Creo que el aficionado también mira un poco eso, ¿no?
O sea, sí que es verdad que me parece lógico
y yo creo que probablemente no le veamos nosotros
tan gran diferencia a lo que es jugar Europa League respecto a Conference,
porque a mí me parece que es mejor jugar Europa League,
pero yo no sé hasta qué punto hay una diferencia tan enorme.
O sea, sí que lo veo tan grande de Europa League a Champions,
pero para mí de Conference a Europa League,
yo no veo un cambio tan grande.
O sea, yo creo que ahora mismo coges a…
O sea, son a Celta y Ray y le dices…
¿Qué quieres, Europa League, Conference o nada?
Europa, antes de que nada.
Hombre, nos ha jodido.
No, claro, portarte un brazo, morir o…
O sea, es que claro.
O que me toque un millón de euros.
Claro, o sea, Alex…
Entiendo que no me explican.
Pero yo… Fíjate si que creo
que hay más diferencia entre Europa League y Conference
que entre Champions y Europa League.
¿Sí? No sé. Yo diría…
A ver, la Conference es un torneo muy menor respecto a Europa League.
Es muy menor, sí, pero…
Y luego el tema de los aficionados que decía Alex…
Hombre, yo creo que me pongo en la piel
del aficionado del Rayo Vallecano, por ejemplo,
y entre ver a mi equipo en Old Trafford
o verlo en la República Checa…
Casi me preocupa el Old Trafford.
En Old Trafford no lo vas a ver.
Claro, o lo ves en Champions o no lo ves en ningún sitio.
No, pero mira los partidos fuera de casa que ha tenido
el Athletic Club, por ejemplo.
Oye, te vas al Olímpico de Roma, a Bulgaria a ver al Ludo Goretz,
te vas dos veces a Estambul, a L'Arrachivis Ictas…
Yo… No sé, te vas a Ibrox…
Yo de verdad que os… O viajes chulos.
O vas a Old Trafford…
Claro que sí.
Yo de verdad que os entiendo, pero creo que el Athletic Club
está en un escalón diferente…
Yo quiero jugar contra el Borat de Bañaluca,
nos ha jodido, claro.
Vete de vacaciones, te vives en coche, te haces los bálticos…
Pero me refiero…
Que te abras la puerta del estadio un ratito
y te hacen la foto, pero…
Creo que… Que juegue en Old Trafford.
Creo que quizá no lo he explicado.
Pero la conference… No, si me lo estás diciendo a mí, no…
Ya tiene, o sea, una situación en la que,
obviamente, vas a jugar ante equipo.
En todos vas a jugar ante equipos medianamente grandes,
porque en premio se va a meter algún grande,
te va a tocar algún equipo grande de estos
que se han despistado en el fútbol europeo…
O sea, que vas a tener esas posibilidades.
Pero no sé.
A mí, sinceramente, creo que la conference es un marrón
por la previa y la Europa League por los rivales.
¿A cuál de vosotros tres os están llamando al móvil
desde hace un ratito?
Soy yo, pero… Es otra cosa.
Tengo una alarma.
Tengo varias alarmas puestas.
No empezamos.
La policía, no…
Son alarmas.
Son…
Me he dejado…
¿Es tu alarma?
No, no. O sea, a ver, no es la alarma de despertar.
¿Vale?
Es una alarma que tengo puesta para acordarme de una cosa
y me he dejado el móvil en otro sector de la casa.
Entonces, como íbamos un poco pillados de tiempo,
cuando hemos empezado, digo, bueno, no pasa nada
porque no creo que me llame nadie.
Y luego he dicho, mierda.
Las alarmas.
No puedes contar…
El mercado del fantasy.
No puedes contar de qué es la alarma, ¿no?
No, sí, sí, sí.
Es porque me tengo que tomar el magnesio
que me va a recomendar el médico.
Joder, o sea, le has dado…
El magnesio se toma por la noche.
Le has dado este aire de…
No sé, de oscurantismo a tomarte magnesio.
¿Y eso por qué?
Porque tengo…
Déficit.
Déficit vitaminario, una chorrada.
Entonces, lo he explicado muy bien, a nivel médico.
No, no, pero sí, tengo el móvil ahí.
Y por no levantarme y no estropear la dinámica…
No, no, no.
…de la previa en la que había tensión
porque había una foto que no iba bien y tal…
Sí, sí, es que…
No quería molestar.
Es que mañana va a salir un tier list de 75 fichajes.
Claro.
Y, claro, las fotos de la Liga son cada uno de su padre, de su madre
y ha habido que trabajar en ello.
Pero bueno.
Entonces, lo que estoy haciendo es, cuando suena la alarma,
me llamo al móvil,
y entonces salta la llamada y se apaga la alarma.
Oye, ¿por qué no te levantas a por el teléfono y quitas la alarma?
Porque no quería que ocurriera algo que está pasando,
que es parar dinámica,
Nahuel ya está diciendo, ostras, el cuané se va a ir a siete horas…
Esta es la típica de que Alex de Llano ha apuntado
hora y veinte minutos de cuané…
Y está poniendo la alarmita.
Estoy poniendo la alarma desde el Mac.
Terrible, terrible.
Bueno, tercera cuestión.
La lanza Pa 1800 desde nuestro Discord,
que lo está gestionando, por cierto, My Boom.
Lo ha ordenado, limpiado, organizado,
os lo recomendamos, lo tenemos en la cajita de descripción.
Magnífico, porque cuando se os ocurra alguna pregunta de cuané,
dejadla en Discord.
No me escribáis un tweet o me mandéis un mensaje por Instagram,
porque os digo guay, os hago like,
pero a veces lo apunto y a veces no, depende de dónde me pille.
El caso es que Pa 1800 plantea una cuestión muy interesante.
Va sobre la selección, pero es muy interesante.
En caso de poder elegir para España, para la selección actual,
un jugador no retirado y recuperar su prime,
¿cuál sería?
Él dice que es Yago Aspas.
Es decir, para traer a esta selección
el prime de un jugador no retirado y que no está ahora mismo con España.
Yo tengo un gran candidato.
¿Quién?
Este pasado fin de semana le metió dos al Inter.
Don Pedro.
Pedrito en la frontal.
Pedrito en la frontal me gustaría mucho.
Juegador muy infralorado en clave de selección.
Acabó un poquito mal, porque no jugaba y pegó una rajadita.
Bueno, aquello fue con el voce.
Claro, han pasado ocho años de aquello.
Más, nueve.
Y camina a los diez y sigue jugando el tío.
Hay dos asteriscos que quiero que regrese a su máximo nivel
y le hace falta a España, que son Carvajal y Rodri.
Sí.
Y luego tengo un par de opciones más, pero os dejo hablar.
Quizás la más clara es la de Sergio Ramos.
Sí.
Es verdad que a nivel de centrales estamos mucho mejor que hace 12 meses,
pero seguramente sea el que no está en su prime.
El jugador con más fracaso en la selección.
Y el jugador que no está en su prime de más nivel en la selección española.
Hay otro que es Busquets, que sigue en activo.
¡Qué cuidado!
¡Ostras!
¡Ostras, claro!
Jordi Alba sigue en activo.
Yo tengo una de Inter Miami.
Y os voy a pedir, chicos, que hagamos un esfuerzo de imaginación importante.
Hay que cerrar los ojos.
¡Saúñiguez!
¿Hay que cerrarlos otra vez?
Si queréis cerrarlos, yo os imagino un mundo…
Cerrar los ojos, ¿vale?
Como suene la dharma ahora, te mato.
Imaginar ese momento en el que llega un joven futbolista de Rosario a España…
¡Venga, venga!
¡Vete a que va!
Pero ese partido que crearon para que debutara con la selección ante Hungría no sucede.
Hay un volcán en erupción y no pueden viajar.
Hay un talén y no sé qué.
¡Y pum!
Llega la federación y dice…
¡Eh!
¿A jugar con España?
Pues, en mi caso, sería a Leo Messi.
No, no, no.
Había que imaginarlo.
No, no, es una respuesta perfecta a la pregunta, la verdad.
A parte de Leo Messi Prime, claro.
Claro, no, no.
Leo Messi Prime.
Claro, pero Leo Messi…
No, a ver.
…juega a la Minyamal, chato.
No, no.
Lo pueden asentar.
A ver, Leo de falso 9, ¿no?
¿Y a Jose?
Claro.
A ver.
¿A José?
A la abrición.
Con el tema del 9, hay dos alternativas de jugadores que siguen en activo y que a España
le harían muchísimo.
Uno es Diego Costa.
Sí, yo era la serie que tenía pensada, pero digo, bueno, voy a tirarme la de…
Y el otro…
Y el otro es Raúl de Tomás.
Muy buena.
Sí.
Un Raúl de Tomás Prime.
Mucho ojo, ¿eh?
Sí, sí, sí.
A ti, Adri…
A ti, Adri, ¿se te ha ocurrido alguno…?
El Isco de Italia.
¡Oh!
¡Qué buena!
Pero es que…
Nos vienen preguntando…
Hay un chico que nos pregunta cada día, en cada Q&A, que respondamos la pregunta de
si estamos viendo la mejor temporada de Isco.
Yo diría que ya le hemos respondido.
Para mí, el Isco de esa temporada 16-17 con el Madrid y con esa cita premundialista,
para mí es el mejor Isco y creo que es superior a este nivel.
Y fijaos que es una barbaridad.
O sea que el Betis es de Isco y ese Real Madrid no era de Isco, pero era clave en la media
punta y España era de Isco en ese sentido.
Yo creo que ese año…
Yo la pregunta que me hago con Isco y molaría que la contesten los véticos, que han visto
muchos más jugadores, tienen mucha más perspectiva histórica, etcétera, es si Isco creen que
va a ser el mejor jugador en la historia del Real Betis por un pie.
El mejor jugador que han visto con la camiseta del Betis.
Como levanta el primer trofeo europeo en la historia del Betis…
Cuidado, eh.
Cuidado.
Un tipo con la jerarquía de Isco de su nivel…
No sé si ha habido tantos en la historia del Betis, que igual me estoy equivocando.
Ha habido muchos y muy buenos, no lo sé.
Algún habrá.
Yo creo que a Joaquín, de lo que yo he visto, porque luego hay otros nombres, pero yo creo
que a Joaquín no lo supera y no por la última etapa, que es buena, sino por la primera que
era salvaje.
Pero es una pregunta lícita, es una pregunta que lo contestan los véticos.
Yo creo que en otro orden…
Oye, me parece que no sería un jugador que, oye, de primer nivel dentro de todos estos
que estamos comentando, pero ¿cómo encajaría Rodrigo Moreno 2019 en esta selección, eh?
Hombre…
¡Qué jugador!
Muy fetiche, con Marcelino García Toral.
Cuarta cuestión, también de Pensar.
Víctor Díaz, Mayo.
Si tuvierais que cambiar a Janoblack, Marc-André Trestegen y Thibaut Courtois en este mercado,
¿qué portero ficharías para cada uno de los tres equipos?
A Joan García para los tres.
Ya vaya, claro.
Claro.
Lo voy a hacer de la jornada de un cabrón.
Yo a Joan García lo tenía para el Real Madrid porque me parece el portero más Real Madrid
de esos tres.
Sí, hombre.
Tiene que ser realista, en el sentido de, hombre, yo si fuera del Real Madrid intentaría
fichar a Don Aruma.
Ah.
Pero claro.
No sé, ¿cómo?
Mira.
Puedo ganar de decir que es el carro de billetes.
Bueno, mira, yo había pensado Joan García al Real Madrid por Thibaut Courtois, Barbe
Bruggen por Trestegen al Barça, que me parece que encaja bastante bien.
Muy buena.
Y lo que vea es que aquí igual se iría al carro de billetes, como decía Nahuel.
Pero sería, ya que no puedes ir a formar Daswili, un portero que tiene alguna condición
parecía Diogo Costa por Janoblack.
Ese sería por… He pensado en el equipo y en que sea más o menos realista, claro.
Es verdad que Don Aruma parece muy complicado para cualquiera.
El que parece que va a cambiar de club y que molaría un montón ver el Atlético de Madrid
es al Divo, ¿eh?
Sí.
A mí me encaja en el Barça, fíjate.
Es verdad que a nivel económico…
Es el tipo del Barça.
… a nivel de sueldo probablemente se vaya un poquito de madre, pero a mí el Divo en
el Barça me puede encajar.
Además, un tipo que oye a los jóvenes, o sea, que viene además ya con un pedigrí,
que yo creo que poco de liderazgo…
¿Y Ayus Kundel encaja?
Depende para qué, ¿no?
Imagínate los clásicos con el Mbappé, el Divo y el Mbappé de Real Madrid.
Uy, bueno, el Divo en el Real Madrid daría cierta continuidad porque pasamos de Divo
al Divo, ¿no?
Hombre, ya puestos, el Madrid se va a gastar una pasta en verano que no fiche portero,
que tiene al Lunin, ¿no?
Yo hay dos que me gustan.
A mí me gusta menos Lunin que la mayoría, pero bueno.
Para el Barça a mí me gustaba Nubel, también apostando por porteros igual un poquito más
consolidado que Berbjörn Brüggen con un juego de pies.
Y para el Ético de Madrid hay un portero parecido a Janoblack, como es Gregor Kovel,
que ya sabéis que es uno de mis protegidos y que me molaría mucho ver el fútbol español.
Bueno, no ha tenido una gran relación el Cholo Simeone con jugadores centro-europeos,
no les ha terminado de sacar ese jugo, pero bueno, a ver si con nuestro amigo Kovel…
pudiera darse el caso.
Es verdad que ella le va a pillar un poquito mayor, pero molaría mucho ver a Sommer en
el Atlético de Madrid.
Sí, sí.
A él molaría mucho.
¿Qué pensaría el Cholo de un portero de metro 83?
Bueno, misma dificultad de aérea que Janoblack, ¿eh?
A mí el nombre que me salía para el Atlético era Mardasbili, porque al final creo que queda
un poquito ese portero super parador.
¿Cómo?
¿Leo Román nos cuadra a ninguno?
Yo es que… Jesús, el magnesio.
Dentro del nivel que estamos hablando…
Es que yo todavía no sé cómo de buenos leos romanos a lo que veo me mola, pero claro,
a Joan García le hemos visto una temporada a un nivel absurdo, es un nivel absurdo el
de Joan García, que de hecho, yo digo, insisto, que si lo puede mantener dos, tres años,
para mí ese es el reto, no superarlo.
Leo Román, yo no le he podido ver con tanta continuidad, pero…
Y luego en el Barça molaría mucho David Raya.
¡Ostras, ya ves!
Yo para mí Raya era un nombre, pero lo que yo decía más en el Madrid, fíjate.
No sé por qué, o sea, obviamente es un perfil que encaja mucho en el Barça.
Hombre, lo que pasa es que hay una evolución, ¿no?
Pasar del cigarros a Raya.
¡Ohohoho!
No sé, no sé…
Sí, sí.
No, no, sí, yo no soy el problema.
Los ciclos de una noche, ¿no?
Yo solo pienso en YouTube y en sus tres strikes, es lo único que pienso.
Ancelati con tomate.
Corramos un tupido velo, ¿vale?
Pero bien tupido, ¿eh? Bien tupido para YouTube, bien.
Bien tupido, claro.
Cat276Creative pregunta ¿Qué expectativas tenéis para la Real Sociedad Girona el año que viene?
¿Pueden ser como el Villarreal este año, que casi se exigía, entre comillas, entrar en Champions, ya que no estaba en Europa,
o sois más conservadores y los objetivos de los dos pasan por pelear para entrar en Europa?
No me digáis, depende del mercado. Eso está claro.
Pero con lo que hay ahora y lo que sabemos ahora, me parece una pregunta muy interesante.
Pues depende del mercado.
A ver, es que…
Pero yo soy bastante conservador por los dos.
Por favor, vea por magnesio.
La Real abre ciclo nuevo y…
A ver, cómo abre este nuevo libro que decía Joaquín Aperriba y el Girona me ha dejado muchas dudas esta temporada.
Creo que ha tenido una pérdida cualitativa en esa plantilla importante, así que yo rebajaría un poco las expectativas con los dos.
Yo sería conservador también.
O sea, me parece que la Real Sociedad va a ser un año, o sea un verano…
O sea, que puede ser una temporada incluso de transición, que no sé si va a tener el tiempo Sergio Francisco para que lo sea,
pero me parece que va a haber tantas bajas y tan importantes, a caso de Zou Dimendi, el caso de Brais,
a ver qué va pasando en distintas posiciones.
Pero luego sobre todo el tema del Girona es que yo creo que hasta la temporada que se mete en Champions,
nadie le pedía a Juan en Europa.
O sea, es verdad que la anterior llegó hasta la última jornada.
Sí, es un caso extraño.
Pero yo no sé si el Girona ahora mismo también por propia presión debe ponerse ese techo.
O sea, entiendo que desde dentro haya esa ambición y que probablemente se busque jugadores de ese perfil para lograr ese objetivo,
pero visto lo visto este año no sé si es el objetivo.
De hecho…
Yo para mí sería un poquito conservador y que intenten pelear hasta el final plazas europeas.
También os diría que nosotros colocábamos al Villarreal muchos cuartos y le poníamos ese objetivo
porque había acabado la temporada como un tiro el Villarreal.
Creo que…
Creo que es que no sé si es la segunda vuelta o el tramo marceíno,
creo que el Villarreal es el quinto de la Liga con más puntos.
Claro, la Real ha acabado hundida, o sea, el último tramo es terrible de equipo de descenso,
el Girona ha estado peleando por la permanencia en la segunda vuelta y en muchos momentos
era el penúltimo equipo de la Liga en puntos en la segunda parte de la temporada.
Entonces claro, como que la dinámica, Anahuel, va a ser diferente sin entrar ya en que encima
en Villarreal ya había llegado Marcelino y por ejemplo en la Real Sociedad Seba y Manuel,
que eso tiene mucho de traumático.
A ver, en el caso de los Villarreales quedaba la sensación de que ya existía un plan
para una vez Marcelino reviviera un poco al equipo y que ya se contaba con…
con que en la temporada siguiente poder aspirar a Europa.
Yo espero más de la Real Sociedad que del Girona,
creo que está algo más planificado los siguientes pasos,
jugadores nuevos que queremos ver, hemos hablado mucho del tema de Gorrocha,
del tema de Urco, creo que tiene con qué hacer la transición,
el tema de John Martín con más partidos en primera edición, de Pablo Marín.
Es que en una temporada decepcionante ha sacado jugadores,
yo creo que muy llamativos la Real Sociedad,
como decís, con el asterisco de ver qué mercado hacen,
pero yo me fío más de esa base que ya tiene la Real Sociedad
que no tanto del segundo año de Crecci, de Asprilla,
que entiendo que va a ser mejor, de Alejandro Frances,
me genera más dudas el Girona ahora mismo.
Bueno, pues vamos a la siguiente cuestión,
de Homo Getafensis, porque dice,
habéis hablado mucho de si Bordalas se va,
pero no habéis mencionado siquiera quién podía sustituirle,
ya tenéis tema.
Ha salido en las últimas horas lo de Celestini,
el entrador del Basilea, ex medio centro del Getafe,
está también ahí el nombre de Luis García Plaza,
que también se le relacionaba con Osasuna,
por dónde creen que van los tiros.
Hay uno que me gusta más,
el mejor entrenador español que queda libre
y que puede entrenar al Getafe, que es Xavier García Pimienta.
En una transición tranquila.
Me gustaría mucho Pimienta.
Había una pregunta que no he cogido,
pero que podemos complementar con esto que dices y con lo que has propuesto.
Preguntaba si una vez se vaya a Bordalas
hay que mantener ese modelo,
que bebe mucho de lo que es José Bordalas
de implantar con otro entrenador,
o hacer un cambio rupturista y volver a lo que era el Getafe al principio.
Estuvimos hablando ayer con Javi Casquero,
pronto se publicará el vídeo de cotillitas con el bueno de Casquero.
Recordábamos la etapa de Schuster,
de Laudrup, de Michel, donde el Getafe
se caracterizaba por ser ese equipo que jugaba bonito,
bien, propositivo, con mucho talento del Valencia,
del Madrid, de la cantera Leti,
y también entrenadores de esta manera.
Ha pasado del blanco al negro, no sé si puede haber un punto intermedio,
pero sí que me parece una cuestión interesante
porque yo decía a Alex en el editorial del otro día
que lo que ahora vale con Bordalas para mantener la categoría,
ni de coña, va a valer con otros.
Y mira que hay buenos entrenadores.
Y mira que hay buenos entrenadores,
pero desde luego que le saquen tanto provecho a tan poco,
a mí el tema me parece que va a ser una transición complicada.
Me parece que lo puede ser.
Y yo no sé, un perfil chaipe y mienta a mí no me encajaría,
y yo no sé si él está en esa ahora mismo.
Pero fíjate que si no hubiera estado en el Leganés,
me hubiera encajado Borja.
Claro, pongamos que en el mundo no existe rivalidad,
pero si hubiera estado en el Leganés,
me hubiera encajado Borja.
Tampoco es una de esas rivalidades
que te dificulta el salir a la calle.
No, pero...
Pero yo no sé si el Getafe va a ir a por él.
Alain Romeo-Nion ha hecho ese...
Sí, Luis Ángel Duque.
Han entrenado a los dos.
Igual Nion no es el único que lo hace este verano,
igual no es el último que lo hace.
Claro, es que encima puede ir Borja.
Como cuando te traían un entrenador para el CAETA
y te traían cinco jugadores.
A mí me encaja mucho Luis García Plaza.
Por el momento, me encaja mucho Luis García Plaza
porque creo que la plantilla no está para dar un giro de 180 grados.
Creo que la plantilla va muy limitada
y que en el post-Bordalás va a necesitar una transición sencilla
de alguien que simplifique un poco el plan.
4-2, 3-1, 4-4, 2, doble pivote muy marcado,
punto por bandas, llegada por los costados, centro lateral...
De hecho, Adri sería un punto gris Luis García Plaza.
A mí me parece un técnico que es muy capaz
de montar muy buenas transiciones ofensivas.
Ha tenido momentos de equipos más conservadores,
equipos más propositivos.
Él ya pasó por Getafe, evidentemente.
Pero sería un punto intermedio entre...
Hay 300.000 entrenadores.
Sí, que tantos.
Yo creo que Pimienta no es un entrenador tan...
...como ha aparecido a veces.
Estoy de acuerdo contigo en lo de que es un equipo muy controlador,
ritmo muy bajo.
El Getafe no es ritmo bajo, es ritmo alto.
El Pimienta construye en corto para atraer
y el Getafe no atrae a nadie, porque pasa de dar pases por dentro.
Entonces sé por dónde vas, pero imagínate los centrales.
Es una plantilla que no da cuatro pases seguidos.
Que no saben dar cuatro pases seguidos.
Tiene un verano.
Después de un verano donde no te ha gastado ni un duro,
yo imagino que al Getafe le van a llegar ofertas
difíciles de rechazar por Uche, por Alderete, por ejemplo.
Y a partir de ahí, montas algo que le pueda acoplar
a tu entrenador.
Mira, yo tengo...
Carmona no es Dani Alves.
La saca mucho partido Pimienta en Sevilla.
El centro del campo es Sevilla esta temporada.
Pero en parte por eso Pimienta está en la calle.
De una manera bastante ronera, como nos han demostrado
el desarrollo de los acontecimientos.
Ha llegado el parlante del Betis esta temporada.
Pimienta parece muy buen entrenador.
Es muy buen entrenador.
Pero ahora mismo, como entendemos que puede ser el Getafe
el año que viene, de cara a lo que han sido
los mercados anteriores del Getafe,
a mí es lo que me deja un poco más dudas.
Yo tengo una propuesta revolucionaria.
Leo Messi, Saúl Niguez, el Tata Martín.
No.
¿Qué entrenador se ha quejado mucho
de lo difícil que es jugar en Getafe, del calor en Getafe...
¿Quién que se tiene?
¡Chavi Hernández!
Ahí está.
Pero...
No lo veis.
Cambiándolo desde dentro.
Si no puedes con tu enemigo, únete a él.
Pero, Álex, ¿hoy qué te pasa?
¿Seguro que es Magnesio?
Dos curifistas, ¿no?
En realidad esto viene porque me he puesto
en los entrenadores libres que pone Transfermark
y, chavi, Eric Tenagno, Máser...
¿Alex Zidane?
Pues mira, le quedará cerca de sus casas y propiedades
en Madrid.
¿Morata, pero entrenador?
¿A ver?
¿Sabes cuándo el árbitro coge un tío
que ha hecho cinco faltitas?
Alguna grosera te diría, incluso dice...
No más.
Fíjate que las estoy cazando muy bien.
Estamos en el periodo más analítico,
estamos tres o cuatro minutos y para que la transición
a la siguiente pregunta sea más dulce,
¿por qué no es más dulce?
Porque es un postre, es como el postre.
Pero más que el postre es un chupito.
Bueno, el otro día probé el tiramisú de matcha.
¿Qué tal?
No me gusta el matcha, pero estaba rico el tiramisú de matcha.
He visto que se ha puesto de moda.
Sí, ya te diría un sitio que lo hacen bien.
Malasaña.
¿De quién esperáis mejor rendimiento
la temporada que viene?
O Río Oskar Son.
Dani Olmo.
Vale.
Mmm...
Yo...
Sergio Gómez.
Mucha realidad, eh.
Entre Real Sociedad y Girona
tienes a la mitad de los fichajes que no han funcionado.
Como volaría Acor Adams.
Acor Adams, de repente, máximo volador de la Liga.
Acor Adams no parece mal futbolista.
No, tampoco bueno.
¿Qué decir?
A mí me...
Sí, pero el Sevilla con el límite salarial más bajo de primera edición,
y pagar 5,5 millones por Acor Adams...
Me parece un poquito...
Libertud, Alex.
El Sevilla necesitaba nueve y solo tenía cinco kilos.
¿Qué decir?
Es caro fichar un delantero.
Trató de fichar uno libre y ya sabemos cómo le salió.
Que vuelve.
La verdad es que
si tienes un entrenador para llegar a Sevilla,
que busques en Google Sevilla fichajes y lo primero que te salga
sea vuelve y je a Nacho...
Claro.
Claro, solo que va a tener un buen asistente.
Yo he fijado, chicos, que tengo mucha fe.
No sé si se le puede considerar decepción,
pero igual algo del que esperábamos más, con Orgalave.
Perdona, con Orgalave.
Logan Costa es un buen nombre.
Es buena. Yo de Connor Gallagher espero poquito.
Si Bordalas va al Sevilla,
¿dónde creéis que queda Peque?
O sea, ¿creéis que os encaja?
En su día,
Bordalas le daba papel a Portillo
para juntar ciertos pases.
Pero Peque es otra cosa.
Sobre todo un llegador, un Juanmi.
Pero yo creo que no tendría hueco.
No será su máximo, bich.
Me empecé complicado.
Yalo también es buen nombre para esta pregunta.
Yo espero más de Yalo.
Algo más tiene que quedar.
Octava cuestión.
Vamos picaditos.
¿Cuántos cálculos llevamos?
38 minutos.
¿Tengo que soltar alguna barra basadora?
Se lo ha tomado como algo personal.
G de Garro.
¿Cuál creéis que ha sido la mejor actuación
de un futbolista en un partido de Liga
en esta temporada?
La de Pedri, antedalético de Madrid.
Esa es la primera que me viene a la cabeza.
En la derrota, ¿no?
Sorloz contra Real.
Estaba pensando...
¿Cuál sería el mejor partido de Joan García?
Pensaba por ahí.
El del Madrid fue muy influyente.
En el del Mallorca.
Pierde el español.
Tiene uno muy bueno que hace la mejor parada
de la Liga, el de Contalgirona.
La parada es salvaje.
¿Cuál es el mejor partido de Joan García?
Tengo muchas dudas.
Batalla contra el Alavés.
Según Sofascor,
que no es media de nada,
pero la puntuación de los porteros suele ir por las paradas,
la puntuación más alta es 1-1.
1-0 del Betis.
10 paradas, un penalti parado.
1,17 goles evitados.
Con gol de Lo Celso.
Le hace una parada en un corner
que es casi a boca a jarro.
Y luego otra que él me dijo en la entrevista
que creía que esa era la mejor.
La que abre la pierna.
La de Jad Gellerrera, que había sido esa semana.
Y él me dijo que las del Betis.
Contra el Atlético de Madrid.
Creo que en ese tramo en el que el Atlético de Madrid
se crece un poco en la primera parte,
que luego creo que el Cholo hace un cambio.
Hay una de Isco ante el Madrid
en ese partido de Villamarín que también es cosa gorda.
Estoy intentando recordar porque hay alguna gran actuación…
Ha tenido muchas, pero algunas que no recuerdo contra quién es,
de Ayose. Ayose tiene algún partido…
Sí, estaba buscando. Pero no lo encuentro.
Yo tengo uno en la cabeza, chicos, de Alderete.
Pero ahora mismo…
Alderete es Vitoria. Vitoria, ¿no? Vale.
65.000 despejes.
Estaba buscando también de la Minyamal.
Yo creo que sus grandes partidos son Champions.
Pero…
Así pensando…
Es complicado. San Cé tiene un hat-trick
ante el Girona, por ejemplo. Sí, es verdad.
Lo comento yo en la tele.
Está el Mamardasville en el Bernabéu.
Igual está romantizado por el tiempo,
pero Swetberg contra el Alavés.
Está romantizado por el tiempo.
Por el paso del tiempo. ¿Os da cuenta, Nao, cómo está?
Laring contra el Valladolid en la primera vuelta.
Pues…
Tiene… El Mapén, Sorrilla. Ah, mira.
Rafinha contra el Celta, el 4-3-S.
Sí, el del hat-trick de Borja.
Pero es que el Barça no juega especialmente bien ese día.
Pero, Rafinha, sí.
¿Hay algún partido de Budimir?
De esos que digas… A ver.
Uno contra… Me suena uno de domingo
a las 6 y media.
Ante la Real, le hace un doblete.
Creo que es el de la Real que yo estaba… 2-1.
Yo creo que esta es una buena pregunta para Kike García
en el Benito Villamarín. Ustras, es verdad.
Y en Sofascor ponen a Vinicius contra Osasuna.
4-0. Ah, el partido en casa.
Sí, el hat-trick.
El debut de Asensio.
Eso es, sí, el pase a Bellingham.
Estoy viendo aquí que también, por Sofascor, el 4-1
con Mbappé contra Las Palmas, que es muy bueno de Mbappé.
Julián contra Betis. Fermín López en el 7-1 al Valencia.
Lewandowski ante el Alavés. Ese partido de Lewandowski es la hostia.
Que es el de que cae muchas veces en fuera al juego del Alavés.
10, 12, 14… Creo que es justo antes del clásico
que vuelva a pasar lo mismo.
Bueno, creo que esta es una muy buena pregunta para que,
pizarritas, nos contestéis en la cajita de comentarios.
No es posible acordarse. Pero de tu equipo sí.
Yo creo que de tu equipo sí. No te acuerdas, seguro.
Sandro contra el Valladolid. O los dos goles.
Entonces, si se os ocurre alguna, cajita de comentarios
Borja Iglesias contra Leganés.
Me ha venido a la cabeza que le recuerdo buen partido.
Lobs… TvW.
Lobs. A nivel de divertimento.
¿Os ha parecido una liga por encima,
en la media o por debajo de lo que veníamos viendo?
O sea, comparadla con…
Es un ejercicio un poquito abstracto, pero…
¿Lo que han sido las últimas cinco ligas en España?
Por encima, por debajo en cuanto a divertimento.
No nivel, no tal… Respecto.
La del año pasado mucho más divertida.
El año pasado fue un poco… Se apagó pronto.
Yo te diría que por encima.
Por encima. Yo creo que por encima.
Yo diría línea. Yo diría que está en la línea.
El Barça muy bien. Nos ha divertido a todos mucho.
Pero claro… Betis…
El Madrid ha reestado bastante el espectáculo.
Los equipos muy divertidos. La lucha de abajo ha estado bien.
La de Europa está muy bien. A mí no me pareció…
¿De abajo la lucha buena?
La lucha buena es la 22-23.
La que pueden bajar del décimo tercero para abajo.
Yo creo que hubo un par de temporadas muy malas.
Hara cuatro o cinco años. Yo recuerdo…
De verdad, de nivel muy duro.
Creo que las últimas tres se ha ido mejorando.
No sé datos de goles.
Habría que concretar. Es complicado.
Pero diría que sí que ha habido esa mejora.
Sí, fue mejorado.
Voy a buscar los datos por partido de goles
respecto a otras temporadas. Porque se tocó suelo.
A nivel de goles se tocó suelo hace cuatro años.
Se tocó suelo.
Creo que la 20-21 es la última que llega apretada al final
por el título, por ejemplo.
El año pasado fueron 2,64 goles.
Este 2,62.
Hace 3, 2,51.
En la 21-22, 2,5.
Y en la 20-21, 2,51.
Un poco entre 2,5 y 2,6.
Es verdad que estuvo el Sevilla hasta las últimas de cambio.
Es la del famoso clásico
de la lluvia.
La lluvia.
A nivel de divertimento,
ver las graditas vacías.
No había nada mejor que hacer.
Era duro.
Con el ruido de fondo.
Las gradas que se superponían
cuando el balón evaporaba.
¿Quién puso carteles de los oficinos?
El Villarreal.
Puso monigotes en la grada.
Un poco duro.
De los últimos siete años, vamos camino.
Es la temporada con más goles por partido.
La segunda mejor, la que es la mejor ahora,
es la anterior.
No estamos mal.
Más remates por partido en una liga.
La 22-23, la 23-24.
Y esta jornada, la 24-25, va a estar ahí.
Venimos de tres ligas a high level.
Por cierto, la 20-21, sí.
Menos goles por partido, menos remates.
Y la última pregunta de Iván 2006, ZZ.
Vamos muy rápidos.
Si sale picadito, sale picadito.
¿Tú habías puesto una hora?
Yo revisaría el cronómetro.
A mí no me ha cuadrado el tiempo.
Se va a subir a YouTube.
Estamos emitiendo en vez de grabar.
Eso ha pasado.
No hoy, pero cuando lo dicen a WEL,
es posible que ya hacíamos cinco o seis minutos
y estuvimos emitiendo en vez de grabando.
Yo había hecho una hora y tres minutos.
¿Cuánto llevamos? 47.
He puesto 1.13.24.
Yo 1.18.20.
Yo 1.5.20.
Por eso he tirado tanta cosa.
Última pregunta.
Si tuvierais que quedaros con un momento de esta liga,
¿con cuál sería?
El momento principal.
Luego recordamos algún pasaje chulo.
Yo me quedaría con la remontada del Barça
al Atlético de Madrid en el Metropolitano.
Era un partido que abría absolutamente todo.
Al Atlético de Madrid hubiese cambiado los dos siguientes meses
de competición, que están siendo especialmente duros.
El Barça se repone un nivel de la mía mal.
Yo me quedo con ese momento.
Yo me quedo con el de la Ida.
El 1-2. El partido de Pedri.
La sensación de que el Barça está jugando bien, pero está a siete puntos de la liga.
Todo precioso, está superabierto.
Nos hizo soñar con un final de liga
bastante más divertido del que hemos tenido.
Yo me quedo con el clásico de Ida.
El 0-4 en el Bernabéu.
Fue la constatación de que este Barça iba muy en serio.
Yo con la despedida de Jesús Navas.
¡Oh, muy bueno!
A mí me parece que es una de las grandes historias de nuestra temporada.
Como han jugado tanto en Sevilla, ha pasado un poquito de puntillas.
Pero me parece que fueron homenajes muy bonitos.
El del partido frente al Sevilla…
O sea, frente al Celta fue muy bonito.
Y luego, sobre todo, también en el Bernabéu, creo que se hizo un buen homenaje.
Incluso el derbi, la forma en la que lo celebró el Sevilla…
Bueno, no lo celebró el Sevilla.
Ganaron el derbi para Navas.
¿A quiénes pulsaron y se disculpó?
Ni a Azú era.
Puestos a pensar en una expulsión, está bien tirada.
No recuerdo.
Jesús, Jesús, perdón.
En cuanto a momento bizarro,
tenemos la peineta de Jaime Mata-Munichy.
¿Cómo se llama el chaval del Getafe que salió contra el Barça?
Isma. Isma.
Es un pick del humor.
Luego también la secuencia
en la que Suezber se queda mano a mano contra…
No sé si era Luis Jr.
Y luego ataca al Villarreal y le hace penalti…
Para el 4-3.
Yo creo que es el partido más divertido de todos.
Era Diego Conde, el portero.
Tiene razón.
Creo que falla uno de los goles y luego hace paradones.
Luego también quedan grandes momentos.
Pase lo que pase.
Balaídos, Vallecas, Mendizorroza, Butarque, Corneal Prat…
El momento Augusto Batalla
pidiendo un minuto más de añadido contra el Girona.
Mira, del Girona yo me iba a quedar
con la victoria de Mallorca.
Bueno, también la del Valladolid, que es la definitiva.
Pero los goles de Estuani,
esas carreras de Porto…
Me parece que fueron momentos muy vividos.
El primer gol de Roberto contra el Valladolid.
Me quedo también con la chilena
de Diego García en el derbi de Butarque.
¡Ostras!
Después de la chupa de agua que me comía aquel día,
al menos vio un golazo en mi portería.
Como celebración me quedo con la del Betis en el último derbi.
La celebración en el Villamarín me pareció increíble.
La imagen de Anthony con la bandera…
¿Y el gol de Anthony al español?
Es verdad que luego no ha cambiado nada
porque el Betis no ha podido pelear por la chambe,
pero no ha podido llegar.
El gol de Antonio de la ciudad,
con un Joan García salvaje,
y el gol del 8 de suelo 85.
El minuto que había sido el 91 de Anthony
por la escuadra con ese plano.
Ese gol es para si se queda Levanés en primera
para que le haga hijo predilecto en la ciudad.
Sí, sí.
La despedida de Immanuel…
Se ha acompañado por las ruedas de prensa
y se ha quedado mucho lío.
Otro gran momento fue el partido en Mestalla
después de la dana.
Contra el Betis.
Se nos está olvidando uno.
Lo comenté yo en directo.
Pues que se te olvida a ti.
La tasa contra Luis Pérez.
Sí, sí.
Es un momento…
El que no has contado que comentaste también
fue la primera vez en los últimos 20 años
que no había un remate a puerta en la Liga.
Un Jeta Ferrayo increíble.
Delicioso.
El partido de Budi Mirenbutarque.
Sí, el que lo falla todo.
Hay una que está a un metro de la portería
y falla como el control.
Esos momentos de derrumbe.
El partido de Girona contra el Betis en casa.
Estos momentos te hacen sentarte delante de la tele.
Cuando un equipo o jugador se cae tanto.
¿Cuál es el gol de Uche por la escuadra?
Que es a pase de Alain-Romeo Niom
que le da la salvación al Jeta Ferrayo.
Bueno, el primer gol de Uche.
Sí, sí, se me refería.
Ah, vale.
Ah, tú dices el de San Mamés.
Claro, yo he ido a San Mamés.
Yo he ido a San Mamés por la salvación.
Ha habido unos cuantos.
En aquel partido de San Mamés tiene un mano a mano
Aleñá con Padilla, un parrón de Padilla brutal.
Le están pitando.
¿Le están pitando?
Padilla en México, ¿hay críticas?
Yo creo que no.
Yo he leído críticas.
Me gustó.
El estadio desde fuera sin estar
en el que más he disfrutado
es con la Comunión Celta-Balaídos.
El partido de la remontante
en Sevilla es colosal.
Hay una comunión desde el principio.
El otro día contra el Rayo es un partidazo
de los dos.
Es un estadio que quiero ir con.
He comentado dos, tres, cuatro partidos,
pero me gustaría estar en esa grada.
En cuanto a estadio que aprieta,
hay una serie de momentos
que me ha gustado.
Hay otro momento muy desagradable
que fue en el Metropolitano
con los encapuchados.
Más que los encapuchados.
Ha habido momentos
en esa línea desagradables
porque hemos tenido demasiados lunes
y días de cánticos racistas
en muchos estadios.
Contra la Minyamal, Vinicius Jr.,
Enyaqui, Uche en segunda división.
Cosas que no nos gusta que se repitan
y que desgraciadamente componen el paisaje.
Vamos a acabar este Q&A
bordeando la hora.
Ha sido picadito.
Le felicito.
Felicidades por este Q&A.
Lo de Messi jugando con la selección.
Chavi entrenando al Getafe.
Se me ha ocurrido hacer un tier
de paridas de Álex de Llano.
La de Saúl en el Celta.
Para mí la de Singhraben es tier 1.
De hecho, Singhraben sería muy bueno
para que me llamaran y me digan
que mira el 11, todas las opciones que tuve.
O Zaharian.
¿Puedo coger un brasileño?
Pizarritas, aquí acaba la temporada
de la Liga Española.
La próxima vez hablaremos de la conferencia
cuando juegue el Betis el miércoles.
Haremos directo de Champions.
Hablaremos del mercado de fichajes.
Todos los viernes publicaremos un Q&A
durante el verano.
Se viene un verano movidito de fichajes,
de contenido y con mucha pizarrita.
Gracias por habernos acompañado todos estos momentos
en la Liga.
Poneos vuestro momento y gran actuación individual
de vuestro equipo.